chaque GPT la révolution de
l'intelligence artificielle la lutte
contre les arnaques sur internet et SMS
qui se multiplient se perfectionne vos
réponses pour protéger les mineurs face
au site pornographique le réseau social
chinois TikTok interdit à la Commission
européenne on va revenir sur l'ensemble
des sujets qui vous concerne en premier
lieu mais d'abord Emmanuel Macron
rattrapé par la réforme des retraites ce
weekend au salon de l'agriculture visite
on va le dire assez houleuse comment
expliquez-vous déjà que cette réforme ne
passe toujours pas auprès de l'opinion
la réforme des retraites elle va
poursuivre son chemin parlementaire au
Sénat et je souhaite que les débats
puissent avoir lieu de manière plus
apaisée parce que je dois dire que je
suis assez écœuré de l'obstruction par
procuration qui a été celle de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pendant les débats à
l'Assemblée ou au fond le projet qui
était porté n'était pas un projet sur
les retraites mais c'était un projet
d'affaissement institutionnel
d'affaiblissement démocratique un projet
d'affaiblissement de la démocratie
parlementaire je souhaite que le tir
soit corrigé au Sénat et que le débat
puisse avoir lieu enfin j'espère que
vous avez bon espoir par ailleurs que
cette réforme soit votée au Sénat je
pense qu'elle va être discutée j'entends
les sénateurs avec l'intention de de
travailler le texte d'aller jusqu'au
bout des débats contrairement à
l'Assemblée nationale ou l'obstruction
par procuration de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ne
nous a pas permis d'aller plus loin que
le deuxième article de ce texte de loi
Bruno retailleul le patron d’éler
majoritaire un groupe Bel-Air au Sénat
affirme qu'il souhaite voter cette
réforme mais après l'avoir amélioré
notamment en accélérant la fin des
régimes spéciaux vous n'avez pas peur
que ça jette un peu de l'huile sur le
feu avant la journée de mobilisation
attendue du 7 mars moi j'ai confiance
dans la sagesse du Parlement dès lors
que il s'inscrit dans une dans une
logique de dialogue et de débat ce que
je reproche à Jean-Luc Mélenchon et à
ses amis insoumis auxquels il a dicté
ses positions pendant le débat
l'Assemblée nationale c'est d'avoir joué
contre le Parlement contre le dialogue
au Parlement et d'avoir au travers
d'invectives d'insultes de provocation
répétée
déstabilisé ce travail là et je veux
rendre d'ailleurs hommage au sang-froid
des parlementaires de la majorité à
l'Assemblée nationale et à Olivier du
sott qui a dû beaucoup encaisser pendant
cette période syndicat l'opposition qui
appelle une France à la réelle vous
inquiète cette journée du 7 mars en tout
cas je souhaite que haut Parlement le
débat puisse se poursuivre nous verrons
ensuite la poursuite du mouvement social
un passons le numérique qui vous
concerne donc en premier lieu Jean-Noël
Barrault vous avez écrit pas mal de
critiques après avoir qualifié chaque
GPT de perroquet approximatif certains
dont eczéma vous accuse d'être dans le
déni de ne pas comprendre cette
révolution alors que l'université de
nombreux secteurs par ailleurs sont
bouleversés par cette percée de
l'intelligence artificielle plus
répondez-vous à ses critiques vous
maintenez d'ailleurs cette cette
expression je suis très flatté que Éric
Zemmour commente mes propos qui ne sont
pas tout à fait de moi il faut il faut
rendre à César ce qui est à César mais
c'est une expression de Jean Gabriel
garricchia qui est l'un de nos
meilleures experts en intelligence
artificielle qui consiste simplement à
dire qu'il ne il ne faut pas
sous-estimer cette technologie chat GPT
en l'occurrence il ne faut pas non plus
la surestimer il ne s'agit pas d'une
intelligence magique c'est une
intelligence artificielle qui ne peut
pas remplacer l'intelligence humaine et
il s'agit d'une intelligence générative
comme comment on dit qui n'est pas
créative qui restitue des connaissances
dans les condensant amassés sur internet
mais comme je l'ai dit l'irruption de
chaque GPT a un grand mérite qui est
celui de mettre en lumière le rôle la
place qu'occupe désormais l'intelligence
artificielle dans nos vies avec un
certain nombre de promesses et un
certain nombre de risques également des
promesses et je pense en particulier au
progrès dans le domaine médical grâce à
sa faculté d'analyser de grandes
quantités d'informations l'intelligence
artificielle sauve des vies elle permet
de détecter très en amont des cancers ce
qui permet de les soigner elle nous a
permis de découvrir en quelques mois un
vaccin contre la covid ça c'est ce que
permet l'intelligence artificielle des
risques aussi et on les voit apparaître
à mesure qu'on utilise chat GPT en
France mais bien sûr à l'étranger les
risques de discrimination de
manipulation de déshumer d'une certaine
manière des discriminations
effectivement via ce
GPT par exemple il y a non seulement il
y a les discriminations il y a pas que
ça aussi il y a la sécurité de nos
données également aussi qui est en jeu
absolument la propriété intellectuelle
la vie privée un certain nombre de
questions
démocratique voire même des questions
éthiques qu'il nous faut appréhender
alors c'est bien se poser des questions
mais est-ce que la France est
véritablement engagée dans cette
nouvelle révolution numérique la France
est vraiment rendez vous de cette
intelligence artificielle aujourd'hui on
sent désintéresse pas au gouvernement
absolument la l'objectif qui est le qui
est le nôtre c'est de maîtriser cette
technologie plutôt que de la subir et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
investissons massivement à la fois pour
former des talents notre objectif cette
former six à 8000 experts en
intelligence artificielle de plus à
l'horizon 207 mais aussi de soutenir le
développement de tels modèles en France
et en Europe qui s'appuient d'ailleurs
sur le français sur notre patrimoine
culturel à nous pour se développer
puisque aujourd'hui des modèles
existants comme comme chat GPT s'appuie
sur le patrimoine culturel plutôt
anglo-saxon et nous avons des atouts
pour y parvenir nous avons des talents
nous avons déjà des entreprises qui sont
assez avancées dans le domaine et nous
allons les soutenir et puis par ailleurs
il faut qu'on investisse mais il faut
aussi qu'on pose un certain nombre de
bornes de responsabilité et c'est ce que
nous faisons en européen puisque la
France a porté un règlement qui va fixer
les responsabilités des concepteurs de
ces systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
tout en facilitant le développement de
l'innovation en Europe je donne un
exemple de ce que fera ce règlement
lorsqu’un un système sera utilisé par
exemple pour les ressources humaines
pour faire des tris de CV ou lorsqu'il
sera utilisé par une banque pour
attribuer un crédit immobilier le
concepteur du système d'intelligence
artificielle devrait avoir préalablement
testé ce système donc en avoir fait état
aux autorités et lorsque des problèmes
de discrimination seront soulevés il
devra les elle est aux autorités donc il
faut un contrôle une vérification
humaine qu'en gros c'est ça la question
que vous avez parlé de ces emplois créés
à travers l'intelligence artificielle il
y a des emplois aussi qui vont être
détruits très clairement ça c'est un
enjeu aussi capital qui risque peut-être
de creuser un certain nombre
d'inégalités aussi dans le pays
l'intelligence artificielle ne
remplacera pas l'intelligence humaine
elle l'assistera donc on y va y avoir
des modifications dans les métiers et
l'enjeu c'est évidemment que la France
et les Français et que tous les Français
puissent bénéficier de cette évolution
produite par l'intelligence artificielle
et ça ça suppose évidemment que dès les
petites classes chacun puisse avoir les
outils pour se saisir de ces nouvelles
opportunités le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé il y a quelques
temps que le l'apprentissage du code
allait être généralisée au collège c'est
une bonne chose qui permettra à chacun à
nous à tous les Français de pouvoir en
bénéficier au delà de ça ce qu'il va
falloir modifier les modalités d'examen
de notation avec l'apparition donc de
notamment de chat GPT je crois en tout
cas que une réflexion sur la manière
dont on intègre ces nouveaux outils à la
fois dans les apprentissages et comment
on fait évoluer nos modalités d'examen
je crois pas qu'il
faut bannir ce type d'outils qui vont de
toute façon prendre une place de plus en
plus importante dans le dans le monde
professionnel mais au contraire
apprendre aux élèves à les utiliser mais
tout en faisant fonctionner leur
intelligence et ne pas se reposer
exclusivement sur l'intelligence
artificielle Jean-Noël Barrault sur Sud
Radio milice délégué je rappelle en
charge de la transition numérique des
télécommunications autre sujet qui
touche des millions de Français ce sont
on en parlait les arnaques sur internet
par SMS vous travaillez à la mise en
place d'un filtre entièrement quelle
forme va-t-il revêtir ce filtre ces
arnaques c'est un fléau les enquêtes
nous disent qu'un Français sur deux a
été victime d'une tentative d'intrusion
qui n'a pas reçu des SMS de l'assurance
maladie du compte personnel de formation
etc etc qui vise évidemment à collecter
des données bancaire ou personnel donc
face à ça nous agissons nous avons mis
il y a 5 ans en place
un site Internet vers lequel je veux
diriger les internautes qui sont
victimes de ce type d'arnaque il
s'appelle cyber malveillance au
singulier.gouv.fr et c'est vers ce site
qu'il faut se tourner lorsqu'on a besoin
de soutien mais il faut aller plus loin
et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président de la République a pris un
engagement celui du déploiement d'un
filtre anti-arnaque qui vous alertera
préventivement lorsque vous apprêtez
parce que vous avez reçu un sms à vous
diriger vers un site identifié comme
malveillant ça sera une protection pour
les Français une forme de garantie de
cybersécurité du quotidien un
avertissement suffisant peut-être pas en
tout cas ce sera la première étape ça
sera une une première alerte qui évitera
que par inattention vous puissiez vous
vous diriger vers ces sites y déposer
des données personnelles ou des données
bancaires qui sont comme vous le savez
ensuite utilisés par par les les auteurs
de ce type d'arnaque pour faire commerce
dans les tréfonds d'Internet
protéger les mineurs c'est également
votre ambition concernant la
consultation de site pornographiques
autres sujets importants pour vous vous
avez annoncé ça aussi la mise en place
d'un système censé en bloquer l'accès
aux mineurs concrètement ça va
fonctionner comment à ce niveau-là
Jean-Noël barreau il y a 2 millions
d'enfants chaque mois qui sont exposés à
des contenus pornographiques de tiers de
nos enfants de moins de 12 ans ont été
exposés à des contenus pornographiques
alors que c'est évidemment strictement
interdit par la loi pourquoi parce que
les sites pornographiques ne font pas de
vérification sérieuse de l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs nous avons pris une loi il
y a trois ans qui les oblige à le faire
cette loi n'est toujours pas respectée
et pourtant des solutions existent pour
vérifier l'âge des utilisateurs les
sites pornographiques pourraient déjà
les avoir mis en place ce à quoi nous
travaillons c'est c'est une une solution
qui garantit le plein anonymat des
personnes qui sous des utilisateurs
majeurs qui souhaiteraient consulter
que vous allez expérimenter à partir de
demain ça consiste en quoi ça consiste à
offrir une solution qui protège les
enfants mais sans fichage et sans
piratage ça consiste en une attestation
anonyme de votre majorité que vous
déposerez sur un site réservé pour les
adultes sans que ceci préservé pour les
adultes ne connaissent votre identité
est-ce que ça sera suffisant là aussi on
le voit sur les réseaux sociaux puisque
les pour le coup les images
pornographiques de circulent pas
uniquement sur ces sites pornographiques
c'est sur les réseaux sociaux de plus en
plus parce que ça va être suffisant
est-ce qu'on a l'impression que c'est un
puissant fond quoi très clairement c'est
un des éléments de réponse l'autre qui
est très important c'est que la France
sera bientôt dans quelques mois le
premier pays du monde a généralisé ce
qu'on appelle le contrôle parental sur
l'ensemble des appareils vendus sur son
sol des smartphones aux consoles de jeux
vidéo en passant par les tablettes
concrètement lorsque vous achetez un
appareil en France par défaut il y aura
un contrôle parental qui sera activable
par les parents qui filtrera les sites
réservés aux adultes qui appliquera les
limites d'âge et notamment celle des
réseaux sociaux qui ont des limites
d'âge que nous allons renforcer
d'ailleurs cette semaine puisque un
examiné à l'Assemblée nationale et puis
qui permettra aux parents aussi de
contrôler le temps d'écran mais la
protection des mineurs sur Internet
c'est une approche multiple qu'il faut
adopter et justement vous en parliez sur
les questions alors c'est la question la
majorité numérique finalement avec ce
député à Laurent par contre j'ai dit qui
appelle à une majorité numérique à 15
ans vous y êtes vous-même favorable
absolument est-ce que ce que propose
cette ce texte cette proposition de loi
c'est de faire appliquer là aussi des
des limites d'âge qui sont d'ores et
déjà plus ou moins fixées par la loi que
que cette loi va clarifier mais surtout
qui sont pas forcément respectés sur les
réseaux sociaux en France en moyenne
c'est 8 ans et demi quoi c'est
absolument alors que les réseaux sociaux
eux-mêmes fixent des limites à 13 ans ce
que dit cette proposition de loi c'est
que au-delà de 15 ans vous pourrez vous
inscrire sans difficulté avant 15 ans il
faudra que le site internet d'abord
vérifie votre âge mais aussi qu'il
puisse recueillir le consentement de de
vos parents et ça c'est une avancée
importante l'actualité journal barreau
ce sont aussi les employés de une
émission européenne donc interdit de
TikTok pour protéger les données de
l'institution ça veut dire que on parle
là d'un réseau social chinois
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a des menaces quant
à la surveillance peut-être de Pékin sur
nos institutions est-ce que nos
institutions françaises nos
administrations françaises doivent faire
la même chose Tik Tok n'est pas au
dessus des lois et d'ailleurs je
rappelle que Tik Tok c'est vu
sanctionner par la commission nationale
pour Informatique et Liberté la CNIL il
y a quelques semaines seulement sur la
manière dont elle manipule les les
cookies qui qui permettent de faire de
de l'identification sur sur Internet et
que deux enquêtes sont en cours par des
cnils européennes l'une portant sur la
protection des mineurs l'autre portant
sur la le traitement des données des
utilisateurs européens à l'extérieur de
l'Union Européenne j'ai sollicité les
les dirigeants de Tik Tok qui m'ont
assuré vouloir opérer le traitement des
données des utilisateurs européens en
Europe à l'horizon 2024 je leur ai
demandé un calendrier devriez précis de
ces décisions là donc pour l'instant pas
question de l'interdire au sein des
administrations institutions françaises
au sein des administrations les
fonctionnaires ont un devoir de prudence
vis-à-vis des des données en particulier
des données qu'ils utilisent dans le
cadre professionnel il existe des
appareils qui sont nativement si l'on
peut dire automatiquement
bloqué pour le téléchargement de ce de
ces applications là d'autres pour lequel
il y a une une interface personnelle et
une interface professionnelle dans
l'interface professionnelle c'est ses
applications sont bloquées et tous les
agents publics sont tenus un devoir de
freelance la lutte contre-la des
informations les fake news c'est l'un de
vos combats ou si Jean-Noël Barrault
quand on faire le gouvernement à ce
sujet ce qu'il faut aller plus loin on a
eu l'exemple récemment de ce journaliste
de BFM licencié pour avoir été sous
influence d'officine étrangères l'un des
informations elle est partout
aujourd'hui dans cette affaire il faut
saluer le courage et le
professionnalisme des journalistes y
compris les journalistes français qui
ont permis de débusquer ces mercenaires
de la désinformation il y a deux ans
mercenaire mais ce qu'il faut pas aller
plus loin à quand on parle de mercenaire
d'abord il faut préserver le pluralisme
l'indépendance de la presse qui a permis
de débusquer ces mercenaires qui étaient
qui se cachaient si l'on peut dire à
l'étranger mais pour agir ce que le
président de la République a mis en
place il y a 2 ans c'est un service de
l'État qui s'appelle vigilum et dont la
vocation est d'identifier et de faire
échec à des tentatives d'ingérence
étrangères c'est-à-dire bien
d'infiltration si l'on peut dire de nos
réseaux d'informations pour déstabiliser
la démocratie ce service vigilume a
permis de d'identifier de faire échec à
cinq tentatives d'ingérence dans les
élections législatives et
présidentielles de 2022 en parallèle
nous avons voté une loi en 2018 la loi
contre la manipulation de l'information
qui a créé une procédure judiciaire
accélérée lorsque des fake news sont
diffusés en période électorale et qui a
créé un devoir de coopération des
plateformes dernière question Jean-Noël
barreau Brigitte Macron qui rêve de
s'inspirer du Pass Culture pour imaginer
une plateforme numérique donnant accès
aux classiques de la température et du
cinéma français c'est une bonne idée
selon vous est-ce que vous soyez
favorable à une telle mesure je crois
que cette toujours une une bonne idée
que de mettre à disposition des Français
et en particulier des jeunes Français le
patrimoine culturel je crois que le
numérique est une est une manière de le
faire et donc je crois qu'on serait bien
inspiré de suivre cette idée là donc
vous pourriez vous inspirer
effectivement de cela absolument après
c'est évidemment un sujet qui est inter
ministériel puisque il y a le ministère
de la Culture le ministère de
l'Éducation il sert du numérique en tout
cas moi je suis tout à fait prêt à y
travailler Jean-Noël barreau merci
d'être passé à ce matin sur Sud Radio je
rappelle Miss délégué à charger de la
transition numérique et des
télécommunications